foreign
might be live already I'm not sure
we're live okay hello everyone
welcome to the channel we are currently
in Malmo
uh at the comp a conference for the
European
Society for the study of Western
esotericism which means it was an
amazing opportunity for me to meet up
with some of my amazing friends
from Seekers of unity
and Dr Angela pruca from Angela
Symposium and Dr Justin Sledge from the
channel esoterican this is actually the
first time we meet him in person all of
us so it's really a great wonderful
moment for all of us
um and we just thought we'd do like a
quick live stream maybe answer some
questions
and hang out for a few minutes so I'll
talk about our experience yes so feel
free to ask any questions in the chat
and yeah
or if you guys about this whole we've
had a lot of theological philosophical
discussions today felt like really
intense yeah it's funny that more people
get together at normal people get
together and talk about like what shows
they're watching we get together and
we're like so what kind of exotic
causations do you believe right
so what is your opinion about
yeah like do you believe in do you
believe in other kinds of Casa okay so
how do you evaluate your a priori
assumptions about reality right right
what's it like well like we should do
favorite colors or something like
something a little
a little lower bar but uh what's your
favorite color Justin
you know that like the BMW makes this
sort of gunmetal blue color so if
halfway between like blue and gray
it's that color I think it may be called
the middle but I don't like the it's a
little too that sounds too intense but I
like that that uh
Spectrum somewhere just between blue and
gray yeah that's nice my wife once said
that her favorite color was white
because it's all the colors at the same
time and I like that answer so I steal
that sometimes
let me guess what Angela's favorite
color is
well it's it's less obvious than you
think my favorite color is actually a a
shade of purple in the color
which is a mixture oh okay is it yours
yes okay otherwise well I'm I'm wearing
amethyst if you can see so I I really
like purple but especially the time yes
especially the type of purple that goes
into blue so like an indigo
at our wedding we had purple as our
color theme
the job to to be in charge of Monday
um questions and comments so if you have
any for us
if you have questions about uh Sufism or
paganism Shamanism Jewish mysticism and
everything in between colors whatever
their colors universe
I always love like a turquoise blue
between blue and green
like this colors or something like that
something like a like a sky thrown blue
film yeah so very
no but I really did as a child not just
because because of the you know
historical or theological significance
so let's go and we could discuss the
metaphysical qualities of color colors
I'm sure what the capitalists say about
God yeah unless you're on the colors
yeah we got some we're getting some
questions but also how colors like it's
like what in the world were they
thinking when they write The Iliad right
like the wine dark sea like what in the
world like how I think it's Jackson
Crawford actually wrote his whole
dissertation on colors and Norse
mythology it's interesting like how even
even what we perceive of as various
colors like is there really such thing
as orange like why do we pick out
certain colors to give names and there's
like really it's a spectrum sure yeah
right obviously it's this literal
Spectrum
um but we pick out certain Shades to
give names like what are the what are
the names of all those colors
we have a question from Jared 33.
I have
have you guys ever experimented with
some of the ancient ritual techniques
you studied and did you get any
interesting results
it's always these questions
we should just go through and be like
answer like you do a like a FAQ top five
and just answer them
So my answer is easy no
my answer is that I only talk about
these things from an academic point of
view on my channel
answer
depends on what you mean by ancient
I think the short answer is no
um
but because I've done field work in in
like Studio context and stuff that's not
really ancient that's like medieval and
forward but I have participated in a
certain
well in the in that sense then me too
but I don't think classifies as ancient
because it's right
we were talking on the last stream we
did about the ancient very very ancient
practice perhaps the oldest practice
known it's been kind of breathing uh and
I get that I do that with interesting
results
um
both as a joke because I breathe and it
has good results but also because
breathing uh there's like new phones I
heard it's a Fab frankly
no this there's a have any of you gotten
into like holotropic breathing or like
like like rhythmic psycho breathing that
kind of stuff
and like the yogic practices like
pranayama
not so many significant degree like I've
tried it once not in a particular form
but like the kind of yoga breathing
techniques
but not really I was just reading about
them some of those practices in America
but mysticism this the other day on the
train oh they have breathing practice
Yeah there's like it's like they
actually are breathing practices
there's an interesting study we made
between Mecca what little we know from
those practices mentions breathing
practices and postures and it's like oh
yeah it's this very yogic sounding and
breathing techniques seemed to be a very
at least almost Universal across
different traditions and stuff clearly
there's something very powerful that can
happen when we
control our breathing in different ways
we have it in Sufism and in Hinduism and
taoism all the way in the Far East and
like hesicism and Christianity
yes
very fascinating yes it's just a belter
Hunter's Point that he made the other
night at the round table we only have
the same brains we have the same bodies
basically and we all need oxygen and how
you and when you deprive your brain of
oxygen the results are really
instantaneous yeah and how are you
systematically derive you know deprive
your brain of oxygen
of course really out yeah it's kind of
cross-cultural reality because it's
right like because we're a
cross-cultural open range we're
cross-cultural ladies yes yeah I think I
think a lot of academic work is trying
to create distinctions and whole
distinctions importantly so between
cultures but I think there's sort of a
new
and I congratically so as you're seeing
a new trend in Academia to point out
that there is something shared amongst
this cultures which is the human
organism and although we may
conceptualize it in very radically
different ways and still fundamentally
is organically the same manner that
we're dealing with and therefore doing
things without breath would have the
same or would have comfortable effects
let's say whether you're doing that in
the Far East or in the near West or down
south wherever right yeah like getting
drunk basically every culture develops
some form of intoxication unsurprisingly
alcohol seems to affect everyone in the
same basically everywhere or you know
whatever lots of different forms of
intoxication
and I think that like in depriving the
brain of oxygen is just another type of
intoxication yeah I mean try to hold
your breath for a while and see you feel
weird yeah yeah like I think that it's
just again focusing on
the
power of intoxication
can this is a question from flights coup
I think we're in it right
can you talk about the differences
between Zen Buddhism and Daoism
you can't I can't come on
I think you're the the
expert here yeah I've studied Buddhism
for a long time even though my
specialism is more Indian and Tibetan
Buddhism but uh taoism and Zen Buddhism
I would say they are pretty different
there are two different religions and
um
Zen Buddhism is it was Zen Buddhism
right yeah okay then Buddhism is
Japanese China Buddhism is Chinese and
incorporates some elements of taoism but
um
it's still not quite the same as taoism
and Buddhism is also quite different
from China Buddhism so they are just
very different religions to be honest
there have been some influences it's a
bit like with
um but drayana Buddhism which is the
tantric for mobudism that has some
influences from Tantra from the Indian
tradition but it's still tantric
Buddhism is not the same as Sandra they
are quite different in Buddhism you have
the old um uh all the basic elements of
the four noble truths and the aim of the
Nirvana as something that you want to
achieve and it's not something that you
really find in Taoism
so they're very different systems I'd
say what would you say is the it's funny
I feel like now I'm not really that the
comparison probably is more feasible
with China Buddhism taoism rather than
Zen Buddhism because then Buddhism is
Japanese what would you say are the main
differences that stick out to you
between the two uh beside children and
being entirely different systems yeah I
think that you cannot really compare
lives and Buddhism and mentalism because
they are culturally very very different
uh so how about chamber or something
that would be the because I I did my
video on John slash Zen I did
distinguish between them in the video
but
um
I discussed the fact that certain
aspects of John Buddhism seem to be at
least somewhere influenced by taoism and
correct me if I'm wrong but for example
there seems to be this emphasis in John
Buddhism not necessarily on nirvana in
the sense of
like escaping or transcending the world
but of
sort of living in the world in a sort of
virtuous with virtuosity with
spontaneous spontaneity and that seems
to me rather similar to certain Taoist
ideas like yes why would you agree
we'd already see
is different a bit like when you look at
advice and
Buddhism I think for a long time I
really struggle to see a difference
between advice and Buddhism because it
seems like
at the end at the end of the day they
both really argued that everything is
you know that there's a known dualist
perspective a very
radical non-wallis perspective because
in Buddhism you have the idea that
nothing exists in isolation that
everything appears into existence in
there's the concept in sanskritious
dependent arising so there's nothing
that appears into existence in an
independent solid and permanent state
so to me that always seemed very close
to the idea of advice but then I think
probably the sort of the sociological
element is different in
vedanta and Buddhism
ever get a whole bunch of Japan
not that I'm aware of it's interesting
but it's interesting what did and play
it'd be curious today I was wondering if
it didn't get a foothold why and why did
Zen get a get its foothold like yeah to
what these don't worry that's something
else about similarity to the indigenous
religion and so I think Zen Buddhism
Incorporated aspects of Shinto
whether that wasn't that already
existing Tradition at that point it's
hard to say but the indigenous
religious tradition of Japan became
incorporated into Buddhism so they I
argue in one of my other videos that
they've become essentially
indistinguishable from each other for a
couple hundred years
something similar happened with uh Ben
in Tibet and uh Buddhism that they
influence each other and I remember that
my professor of Tibetan used to say that
if you go
um in Tibet it's very difficult to
distinguish a Buddhist
separate place from Auburn civil place
in terms of you can always tell where
the old Shrine Pagan shrines were yeah
like you can tell the word the capital
of was because that's where they tore
everything down and build a church of it
so it's like that sort of the
assimilation and you'll go up to uppsala
and the big church there where they yeah
tore everything down
trying so I think Daoism made its ways
somewhat into Korea more so than Japan
but this is not my favorite expertise
but I don't find a lot in a lot in Japan
and also why why East in that West to me
outside from the fact there's a mountain
you know
it's been good but it's interesting how
like something like a mountain can
determine
Which Way religion goes
with photography play the decisive role
and
how how relatives travel and like it's a
silk road like we both have been we've
got to see this recently they found
those little statues of the Buddha in
Egypt
I didn't see that yeah I think one of my
favorite things is actually here uh it
really your studies wise actually here
in Sweden but in Stockholm in the museum
they have that exploded grave of a
Viking Chieftain and sort of you walk
into the grave and it sort of like shows
you all the things in space around his
body uh and one of the things he had was
a little statue of the Buddha wow that
probably came from Afghanistan as well
so we had tons of Islamic coins for
silver and like he had this little
buddha and you're like what in the world
was a viking Chieftain doing with a
little Buddhist that's true
um it's like this shows you how far
things can travel in the ancient world
we can often have a bit of physical
objects can travel that far certainly
ideas can yes and we often imagine the
ancient sort of people back in the day
has been completely shut off from each
other but that's really not true at all
yeah and so there's always a speculation
to what degree did you know the gym most
of the so-called gymnosis where they
look at their ideas over across the
spice Road or whatever like to what
their Alexander's always press into
Afghanistan and you get discount to RNR
it's like this beautiful mixture of
Indian and classical Greek art like how
much was also because boost we know the
Buddhist missionaries were being sent
and did arrive in in Egypt they were
actively out there competing with men
cans and stuff
it's a great movie you made about that
like
where you just get a mix of like the
maniki the manikin guy and the Buddhist
kind of like having a debate about them
about I mean it's such a cool scene from
a movie because if there isn't a movie
if there's a movie no I don't know why
no I thought you said there was there is
no no there's a movie I get to see this
one yeah it'd just be the most
interesting you have to make it yeah
yeah we gotta get in the filmmaking yeah
we have some some fun questions here
both some technical ones and some more
sort of broader abstract ones there's um
someone hit a question the username is a
string of lettuce I'm not going to try
and read it is the Virgin Mary story a
translation mistake from the Old
Testament into Greek and then there's
some more important questions if these
questions are too technical like the
idea that she was a virgin yeah yeah the
part the nails
problems
right I think it's a translation mystery
but I think it's when the rabbis made I
think whoever translated translated on
purpose they knew that word they
mistranslated on purpose yeah yeah I'm
gonna do some context there anyway so
the
though in in the the version Isaiah says
and a young woman will conceive a child
Alma which Lord Alma can have all kinds
of balances but it can even have
valences of professional non-virgin and
even like mean sex worker so it can have
a range of valences but there's a
distinct word in Hebrew for Virgin but
too long
um and the Hebrew is not the two law but
when they translate it to Greek they
translated as part of the name is
definitely means version and so the real
the question is why did very Jewish
Scholars elect not to try to translate
and I think an uncle does too it just
translated over us our uncle loses the
Arabic translation of the Hebrew Bible
it also just reduces
yeah it see it seems to me like the the
author of Matthew is intentionally
translating there as as virgin right
because at the end of the verse which is
and he's named and the child's name
should be called Emmanuel garudas and so
he's it's the end of the verse which is
informing the way that he even known us
and it's funny because Matthew's gospel
is the most Jewish gospel and yet he he
leans so heavily on the Greek
translation which was a very Jewish
translation very septuous Jewish book
but it's an interesting moment where
this very Aramaic sounding thinking
writer leans Greek because he needs the
the birth Miracle really he really needs
to get off the ground but I don't know I
don't know if it's a mistranslation but
it is it there there's there's so
there's some there there and it isn't
straightforwardly the word for two lies
right so to answer the question I I
would say that it's not a mistake it's
an intentional transformation yeah
that's what I've always considered I
don't feel informed enough to to have an
opinion but I trust these two but I will
say that sometimes so much some world
history has turned on that and on that
uh on that uh here's a greater question
created that create a translation Beyond
just the the book of scholarship with
the this is from Leonardo capstick with
the so-called new atheist movement dying
out do you think and the scar points are
there in the question do you think
public discourse about religion will
improve
[Music]
I think that they don't control I don't
think they have hegemony on that on that
conversation anymore
um yeah that's different from buying out
it's more losing the Germany over the
public conversation right but I think
it's I think that
aside from the dark corners of Reddit
where the where the new atheism which is
is uh pretty popular I think that people
are definitely ready for a more nuanced
yeah conversation about religion and
they realize that that even atheism is
actually a religion well I would say
even if it's there's a lot of nuances
to non-theism sure and militant
Evangelical nontheism is actually just
one vocal frankly irritating camp but I
think there's lots of non-theisms out
there like I'm a non-theist but I'm
pretty interested in having very subtle
conversations about like for instance
the mysticism and mystical experiences
but I think are totally available to
non-theists and so I think that they're
I think the public is very interested
eager to have conversations around
religion that are a lot more subtle than
evolution is true God's dead like that
it's like you know 16 year old ninjas
nietzsians we could use a lot less you
know in the world right so let's say the
question is if the if that movement is
is like dying out will that improve the
the discourse about religion I think
hopefully because my opinion has always
been that the kind of new atheists
position is often based on a very
shallow understanding of religion to
begin with yeah and if it's sort of
dying out or if they're losing hegemony
over the conversation maybe that's the
result of people being
or at least wanting to be more informed
than having having more nuanced
discussions on religion and that's in
that case I'm I definitely think it's
it's a sign that that yes we're getting
yeah we also look a lot better right
we're we're proof of that right like if
this is between the all of us sitting
here we have different beliefs we have
different beliefs but also we have
almost a million subscribers right like
people are interested in having deeper
conversations about religion and I think
that Richard Dawkins level right like
like yeah that may be good on the
science but they're really bad on the
religion and I think that having
more deeper more sophisticated
conversations on these topics I think
where the fact that our channels are
successful in the way that they are so
to me a good evidence of that the the
the the debate is that people's interest
is shipping and they want more subtlety
about it yeah I would add that it's
that's the let's say
the the dying hegemony of the new
atheism so the end of the hegemony of
religion it's they both are those sides
need to come down for a nuanced
conversation to imagine I think that
people feel people in a more at least
impossible but a more liberated from
oppressive from this religion you now
have the freedom to turn back to
religion on their own terms to ask of it
their own existential questions
and that's something that I've seen in
my own value my own friend groups I
missed a fun question here from earlier
did you join us at something angel
I agree with you guys I think that is
you have a nuanced conversation I think
that people now are also ready for for
that I think there was a time when
um people believed that we were going
towards a secularized age and more and
more people would would become atheists
or non-religious
but I think that even though the term
that Peter Berger the sociologists of
religion had turned against his own idea
of uh initial idea about the
secularization Theory then he moved on
from that and he said well actually we
don't live in a secular age we live in a
pluralist age where you have multiple
layers of beliefs within families and
even within one person so I think that
also the the idea of religion that we
have has changed I think that what
people thought of as religion was
something there was uh heavily Christian
or abrahamic base
and now it tends to be a bit more
nuanced and complex that's why a lot of
people that do not abide by the three
main monotheisms used to say I'm
spiritual I'm not religious and there
are Scholars that have studied the
so-called nuns which are the
non-religious and it turns out that they
are actually very religious indeed it's
just that the way they classify religion
is an institutionalized form of religion
that resembles especially Christianity
but also Islam and Judaism so they see
that as a structure that they don't
identify with because usually people
that identify as spiritual want a more
eclectic individually tailored approach
to religiosity but it is still religion
it's just that they didn't call it
religion because because of that because
of that bias or what they thought of as
religion we had a follow-up question
here which again another sort of big
question is religion important yes
yeah yes
it's important
it's important as a as a subject of
study because it is important to people
around the world which means it's
important for us
to understand it understand how people
relate to it and how people what
relationship people have to it
let's talk religion yes that's the whole
point yeah I mean I would say not only
is it important just as a fact but I
would say it's important as a discourse
because unlike philosophy which operates
ideally it's like an interrogative
discourse that asks questions I think
what makes religion so frightening and
Powerful is that it's a it's a discourse
of absolute belief of absolutes and that
those people whose plan who who they can
speak on behalf of the gods they have
enormous Social Power
so I think that in that way
being able to interrogate religion is an
incredibly important human right yes I'm
thinking about human rights discourse
and interrogating religion
freedom to religion and also freedom
from religion but also freedom to
interrogate religion
I think that is just the the question
about religion is just unavoisable
because I would argue that every person
has religious beliefs events and even
the
agnostics I mean you can it is still a
religious stance yeah if you say I don't
believe in God or
um I suspend my judgment about God the
gods the Divine the metaphysical world
that is still a religious stance and
that is still affecting the way you live
in society the way you live your life
the way you interact with people so I
think that religion is very very
important to understand
everything about human society history
sociology how we relate to society it
just permeates everything yeah I have a
question for you Angela
um with everyone but maybe you first and
this is from
I'll find the name in a second because
it's jumping around uh from Ahmed shayo
is there a difference between paganism
and Satanism
no no hey
yes there is a difference between
paganism and Satanism and when when I
talk about paganism
now I'm currently co-editing the volume
for equinox on piglet religions in five
minutes which is part of a series of
religion in five minutes and
um Susan Owen and I are curating the
Pagan religion side and
um that's one of the questions that
because it's one of the most asked
questions so when I talk about paganism
I talk about contemporary paganism the
capitalized paganism because paganism
from the ancient words Scholars don't
capitalize it so the way we distinguish
between the two is not capitalizing the
ancient form of paganism and
capitalizing contemporary paganism
whereas in the past there used to be the
term neopicanism which Scholars are now
um not using uh anymore or we prefer
contemporary veganism but anyway no it's
not the same as Satanism because
contemporary paganism is
a new religious movement that is that
has certain uh main traits it is it
tends to be very nature based it tends
to be to worship and align with the
cycles of Nature and it doesn't really
employ Christian or abrahamic World
Views because it's vegan so there's
paganism has its own worldview and its
own way of conceptualizing disease and
Satanism is very much rooted in
Christianity and
You could argue maybe in abrahamic
religious system but I think the system
is very much linked to Christianity uh
in the way it is it is conceived and the
idea of Satan is formed because in the
Hebrew Bible Satan is not really well we
can understand it now in the public
discourse when we talk about Satanism
something that that's quite different
and has developed in a certain way via
the Christian discourse so no I would
say that paganism is not and I repeat is
not the same as Satanism because we can
say we don't even believe in Satan we
don't believe in the Christian
uh mythology so how could we worship
Satan how could we worship the devil so
that's not really what um figures do
I could make things more complicated but
it's better today yeah that was a great
answer yeah yeah I think that yeah it's
just like simply put there it's hard for
pagans to be satanists if there's no
Satan in their opinions yes how can you
be a Satan if you're not there's no then
die yeah if you don't endorse the the
Christian
and also the other way uh the way uh
pagans see the Divine and deities is
completely different from Christianity
you don't have the arch enemy or the
pure evil pagan gods and pagansetties
are all good and evil according to the
way we say good and evil I I don't think
that Pagan believe in Good and Evil
anyway in in such a demarcated
ontologically moral ways so it's not
something that can be so easily defined
pagans tend to believe in um in an
Ethics based on the individual
responsibility
then it also depends on the type of
pagan because like in wika you have
threefold law which means the uh
everything that you do good or bad which
we could
um better words might be beneficial or
harmful anything that you do comes back
to you three times forward that's one
part of the we can read but this is
something that we can't believe whereas
other types of pagans don't abide by
that and they just say that they believe
in an Ethics that is based on individual
responsibility you don't have God's
deities that will send you to a place or
another depending on the actions that
you take so it's all based on individual
responsibility and you may ask so how is
the individual responsibility assessed
many pagans believe in our animes or
panties they believe that Divine is
imbued in everything and many also
believe in a sense of interconnectedness
of things so usually there is a sense
that like probably many people as well
the idea that you want to do good to
others in terms of being beneficial and
creative because you are adding to the
interconnected whether you're part of
your acting you are contributing in a
creative way and not in a destructive
way so it's more a sense of I'm part of
this interconnected web the more benefit
and the more creative energy I can input
into this web the better because I am
it's not a sense that somebody is going
to punish me if I don't it's more sense
that I feel that I'm similar to you I
feel that I'm similar to a plant to a
chair to everything so that contributes
to
how you assess ethically what to do and
what not although it's very complex
because of course figures also accept
the idea that destruction is also part
of Nature and so there should also be
embrylist so it's actually a very
complex discussion but I hope that gives
why do you think some people would even
equate Satanism antagonism I think
that's because
um for a long time Pagan has been used
on Christian or non the religions that
I'm part of I think that also in Islam
and Judaism right you have the idea of
pagan as
do right so first we use them it's not
we don't the word there's no word in
Hebrew pagan
like there's other words for Outsiders
but there's no
there's no it was it was invented by
Christians or like and even even used by
ancient pagans to describe people in the
countryside it just means like people in
the countryside right yeah it means uh
Pagan comes from paganus pagan
dweller of the pagos the pagos sees a
rural Place basically so it's the uh it
was a term that was a derogatory term to
call people that lived in rural places
and where you know so ignorant or
backwardly that they wouldn't confess to
Christian so it is I think a happily
Christian
it has a heavily Christian connotation
in that sense so I think that's why uh
viewed from a Christian lens people
would equate paganism to Satanism
because it's the evil you know it's what
is not Christian and if you're not
Christian then you must be evil so equal
Satan which is interesting because they
had a special word for it
like they could have just called them
satanists but they didn't like clearly
like just because you're ignorant rural
person
doesn't mean I don't think that at the
time they had the concept of Satanism I
think when the term Pagan came out
like because even I think even so-called
pagans use it too like I think I've I
think I've read that like Elite Roman
writers would also describe people who
lived in the countryside as paganas
the Christians adopted that language
because they're not speaking Latin
originally the technical language that
that uh that develops in the Greek words
areos they're Heretics they believe they
have incorrect opinions so I think it
develops later in the Roman West
instead of other Romans
kin is maybe a translation of it
no because
some of the scholarly work that I've
read it seems that the festival
currencies are from Christian authors
um if I remember what's the the action
this first one
or something because because the same
term is not used in Greek they don't
have a term like that
they would have like a equivalent term
I think continue to talk about
heretic heresy early is early picked up
in the Greek word like
word is that language
I don't think that's an equivalent
like in Islam is like a nice convenient
word for people who don't convert
so we don't think the board like that
ever but there's no never a safe it's
really clear vocabulary and early
Christianity
the closest term to something like that
as a slur in Judaism is like Abu dazara
like foreign worship but
but there's no like there isn't a term
for someone who does Abu dazza
well you would just call them
or someone who is an event
right yeah that's in the in the legal
texts like
people who worship Stars
but
foreign
typically describes things that Jews
aren't allowed to do
not necessarily there's a kind of
concern that if you're on some other
team you're on some other team are you
doing you do you should do whatever you
want or you should do whatever but
there's a sense of like
if you're a Jew you can't do certain
kinds of things you can't appear like
yeah it's much more concerned about what
Jews do and don't do it as opposed to
like what Christians are Persians or
their aspirings did
we try to um like like a lightning round
of questions because we have a lot of
wonderful emotions that just keep speed
dating
okay
um have you ever dealt into a topic and
be amazed by how much you've learned yes
yes but more so how much I don't know
yes that's great
um thoughts on free will do we have free
will or is everything determined yes yes
I think that the concept of Free Will is
very Christian so the the idea of Free
Will is a Christian concept I would see
more as what amount of agency do we have
I would reframe it that way because I
think that having free will or not
having free will is a very Christian
question
foreign so I think I I'm not a
determinist
but I think that compatible with
something we call it
what compatibility that would be
something I can compatibilize but I
wouldn't be able to formulate in what
way but I I think
um yeah yeah so no for me it's more a
matter of what degree of agency I have
because so in a way I'm sort of
determinist but to a degree so I think
there are some things that we are
determined by and others that we have
control over and the the amount of
agency that you can have the extent of
agency that you can have varies
depending on multiple factors maybe
including magic
about this in the car yesterday and
there was a quote which I which I put up
from the David Lloyd a great scholar I
wrote a book on Buddhist and Hindu
imperative studies non-duality between
the two and he writes that uh if we're
to take a
a let's say non-dualistic position which
is a topic we study then ultimate
determinism and ultimate Free Will
coincide in that moment and I found that
to be a persuasive position I guess I
should also say even though I'm a pretty
hyper determinist I'm also kind of
confident about this and say that that
Free Will is a regulator of Ideal was
necessary and therefore but I would say
that I would say that it that Free Will
functions as a as a regular ideal a la
but it is regulative and ideal
it's really important right
but but actual like if I'm like just
just going in at straight
um
like first order metaphysics
for that matter physics also now seems
to be completely indicating inside
question from Colin uh Gallagher how are
you guys
I'm doing good I'm happy to be
hanging out with wonderful friends
likewise for the first time we will meet
in person
yeah I think it's like I'm I'm sort of
in that part of my journey actually
that's like a hot like a big or like in
this like in this lifetime yeah your
time sounding like I miss you yeah
Mystic no like I mean it's like my time
in Europe or like I'm first shooting I'm
hitting that first wave major way of
like of uh homesick
you know I'm healing feeling that but
also
it's just like especially for most of us
have been traveling we really
been doing okay fine
like I've been in how many countries now
for some period of time like at least
four
in the past like two seven days so let's
uh yeah good but like
good that you can I can I'm glad to see
the light at the end of the time you
were in four countries just yesterday
yeah yeah yeah yeah so are you getting
back on Wednesday
to the US I'm going back to Amsterdam
for Wednesday I'll be there
um so you're saying I'm staying for one
night I'm sorry I'm just to like have a
night to myself I'm like walk the
streets and uh because I also skip over
such a nightmare that did not want to
get there the same day I was flying
that's cool
to burnout and I apologize for
mispronouncing that Alex asks who is the
most important political theologist
oh wow
important
he doesn't specify if it's contemporary
or like historical the entire class like
what we're talking about political
theology or we're talking like what I
guess it depends on how how those
adjectives announcement
because there's a political theology
which is
like
that's a whole domain of philosophy
there's important philosophers in that
who aren't I mean
orgasm probably that's the name that
came up in my head too yeah custom like
more did more to shape the tenor of
things like just word theory and what
makes a legitimate Sovereign and
there there is no there's basically no
political Western theological problem
the theological politics right outside
of Augustine it's a it's a simply it's a
super intimidating work but if you've
never read Decatur today
it's it's probably the only city of God
the city of God's been has those there's
also important stuff in magic in there
as well fourth reading because for that
if you just want to do the magic stuff
but I would say that in many ways
like Western Civilization Western Latin
civilization is basically a dialogue
with that book it's a huge way let's see
if we can get a short answer on this
Samir karki says is Satan better than
Jesus Satan better than Jesus
it's better that I don't know
I don't know
no answer that you I mean I'm not a
particular fan of either frankly
I don't know why but your question
reminded me of some
Jesus loves you but Satan can do the
thing with his dog
I hope you're not getting in trouble
there's always great yeah there's always
these great uh Jesus can do this but
so-and-so can do this yeah that's it
Jesus says what Moses and best
it's like a little bit because
I like Jesus better
that's my answer yeah I'm not a fan of
either
I don't have a preference
and you're leaving yourself out of these
questions
you can't moderate yourself out of these
he's he has I don't know if I fully
understand this question
um but if you guys do
you feel that modern psychology has a
line to esoteric slash Mystic thought or
is the apparent need for scientific
ideas to have a definable and discrete
categorization in any reconcilable
difference
two very different questions the first
question is definitely yes there's no
modern as a terrorism without younger
true just like period they're like
listen like the or not it's human but
also like before too like Alistair
Crowley in the goisha his version of
goisha even says things like the goetic
demons or just regions of the human
brain so like he was even that early in
the
early 20th century was very clearly in
Heavenly now Crowley changed his mind
about that and began to believe in the
independent existence of these entities
toward the later part of his life but
there's no esotericism question without
me yeah I also have a video on the
uh probably end up psychologizing of
entities
but yeah I agree I think that psychology
definitely changed to gain other study
season that probably was conceptualized
and also opened the floor for the
so-called soft polytheism
um and I also have a video on that
difference between hard politicism and
soft Politics on my channel and the idea
is that in hard politicalism people
think that there there are different
entities that are ontologically existent
and independent from us well soft
policyism is more the idea that gods
exist in relation to us in in certain
way like for instance there could be
archetypes like Eros could be the
archetype of fashion within ourselves or
um that could be seen as forces of
nature so it's a way of seeing the
deities that is considered soft because
they are not ontologically real in and
of themselves but they are real in
relation to certain aspects of of us
which are usually uh heavily
psychologized
and I think that there are also some
atheists which is that adopt forms of
soft polytheism and they argue that that
is a form of atheism which is also
interesting others others don't see that
as a form of atheism they just see that
as another type of politicism
also I would say it's not just
esotericism but like
modern religion like there's no exotic
and there's no like me accessorism also
it's Downstream of this shift it's just
a
people say what they want to about
psychoanalysis but there is no majority
without no contemporary intellectual
world without it
for better and force
thoughts on
perennialism
it's a question we had a whole we had a
whole discussion about this like a year
ago yeah we did we did a whole election
there aren't preeminine Scholars that I
definitely admire
I think that perennialism can be a
viable spiritual tool for people who
believe in that but academically
speaking that would be terrible because
perennialist view adopted as an academic
I think that it would go outside of a
rigorous methodology that leads to
Accurate knowledge
um also I think it's like a function of
like this weird thing I don't give you
that look at these comments too on your
channel but there's a tendency of the
human mind to assume that because two
things can be compared they must be
connected right yeah like I sometimes
call compare Mania that like if two
things can be compared they must be
connected and
the idea is that
comparative is not is not uh it's not uh
it's not a ground for any ontological
connection whatsoever
but like oh this Godzilla associated
with lightning in this conversation with
lights they went from the same God
there's no that doesn't logical bullet
and it certainly doesn't historically
we have some super chats which we can
pull up here as well thank you oh yes
thank you yes
um smashing Paper Tigers good name asks
do you think contemporary Pagan
religions will become more organized
in parentheses communities places
worship legal recognition Etc over the
next 50 years question mark
I'm guessing that's a question for me
sounds like it is
um so it depends what you mean by
organized in terms of having more places
of worship even though pagans would I
don't think they would use the term
worship but sacred places to practice uh
yes and I think that's happening already
even in Italy for instance there's the
goddess temple in Rome and there are
very few temples Pagan temples or Pagan
secret places in Italy but they are not
institutionalized because there is an
essential Dogma or a central Authority
in paganism and in terms of whether that
will change whether paganism will become
more institutionalized like other types
of religions that are more dogmatic and
more institutionalized I don't think so
and at least I can talk I can use the
case study both Finland and
um Italy because in both places at least
I'm sure that it probably happened in
other countries is too but in both these
countries what happened is that in order
to get legal recognition as a religion
there was
um they formed a group to to do that but
in Italy and uh the same happened in
Finland there's a paper by timothara on
that if you want to look that up
um it's a peer-reviewed paper which I
when I read it it's like oh the same
thing happened in Italy and what
happened is that since to be recognized
as religion in Italy you need to
resemble
Christianity basically
there was a massive fight within the
Pagan community and they said no we are
not doing this we'd rather not be not
classify as as a religion than just
um alter the the very nature of paganism
so there were very few that were trying
to do that and they were accused of
wanting to become the popes of paganism
so that didn't go down well
I like their name paganism
so I think that
um paganism is very resistant to
institutionalization and I think that
men pagans are
anti-dogma and anti that kind of
uh structure so I don't think that that
is going to happen What might happen
more is the fact that different
Traditions within paganism might become
more organized but at least I don't see
anytime soon paganism becoming more
institutionalized in that sense and if
it gets recognized as a religion which
in a way indeed the the bridge Droid
order got the charity recognition as uh
as a religion but you need to have a
country that has a view of what
constitutes as a religion that doesn't
resemble abrahamic religions and you
don't like that term I'm sorry how can I
call it the three one of the Asic
religions this is also why governments
need to have religious studies people
working for them because otherwise
they're going to make really bad stupid
policy decisions and really discriminate
against people so what I see more
happening is probably governments and
the public discourse around religion
changing to the point where a religion
like paganism which is very different
from umbromic religions can and be seen
as a religion and it doesn't have to
change its its very nature to to be
recognized as such and also since vegans
are generally quite anti-dogrammatic I
don't think that they care as much about
the label they care more about what they
believe in and the practices and the
fact that they remain you know the way
they they are with that kind of mindset
does does Italy recognize Hinduism I
don't think that Italy recognizes uh
Islam I think that one of these yeah I
think doesn't recognize Islam as a
religion I think the problem was also
the same that it doesn't resemble that
because the the lower round recognizing
a religion was I think it still dates
fascist era so it won't surprise anyone
yeah I mean Islam is relatively yeah
similar in structure it is it is present
in Italy as well but uh as far as I know
I think that the time at the time when
these all Pagan thing happened in Italy
was
2007 2008 and I remember that there was
a whole conversation about the fact that
not even Islam was recognized as a
religion and there was a whole
conversation in the bigger Community
about that and the fact that the the
problem was more than the law had to
change rather than uh the pagans had to
abide by those those standards and that
was the the winning argument was this
one was that we shouldn't try to uh seek
religious status
as since things are like this now we
should try and change
the government considers to be a
religion and that and that will benefit
not only pagans but also Muslims and
other and other people so that was the
winning argument within the Independent
Community
interesting that still happens today
because I I'm reminded of Sikhism under
British colonial rule which you know if
you wanted protection as a group or as a
religious group you needed to be
seen as a religion and so the Sikhs at
least this is what a lot of historical
scholarship says
uh we're also somewhat forced to shape
their religion according to like a
Christian or abrahamic framework in
order to be seen as a religion on its
own to get the kind of
protection for the government
Buddhism God the recognition because
they created them an organization don't
quote me on that because I can't
remember the details off the top of my
head but if I remember correctly they
created like an organization called
um
the Buddhist Italian something and so
the association got the the recognition
but I think that the process was that
you have to create a sort of
organization
in order to get together in
legal recognition which is strange I
think that the law should change but
yeah yeah it evolves written during the
fascist period should be re-evaluated as
an idea it's like you know the fascists
weren't so great at making Fair laws in
my in my understanding of what they were
up to it's my impression as well
do you know of any successful attempts
to rebuild any sort of the an old North
symbols here in Sweden and upsella are
seems like you know since the Christmas
tour down there their temples and foot
churches there it's like the pagans
should be able to yeah throw a throw a
temple up next door at least
I don't have any temples but there are
definitely like smaller shrines that are
put up and I know the Stockholm named
himself for example and there are groups
that are holding like bloat ceremonies
I'm not sure about their like legal
status actually now that you
ask
because I know that we got Pagan's got
Wicked if he's got recognition by them
in in my lifetime in the US but like in
the military where they could get uh I
think one of the guests that was on your
Show recently was really responsible for
that
um where they were able to get uh Pagan
Wicked imagery on their tombstones for
veterans I've been to a graveyard
um a veteran graveyard where I saw a
couple of those good very like again
like for a person who for me cares about
freedom of religion seeing that yeah
that's nice I was like okay well it's
good it's like at least people can rest
of their symbols that that uh served
their country they should be recognized
yeah we have another Super Chat here
from
Louis Jorge which is one of their first
Super Chat thank you thank you very much
for the four any interest in
Mesoamerican folk religion
sure
definitely I don't know much about it
but I I've been looking into
to making some content about that which
is a great excuse for me to learn new
things I would love to cover the Aztec
religion for example I know Andrew yeah
Andrew Henry from religion for breakfast
made a video on
he also made one on the Maya religion
and they're both great so if you're
interested you could definitely check
those out
um
mysticism related to bloodletting yeah
one of my favorite names of all time is
uh it could be named something like
jaguar Shield heavily scarred foreskin
you can earn the title of heavily
scarred foreskin
man it's like some culture is just like
that's a metal metal pure metal
um
there's a friend of mine who's done a
PhD on Maya archeology so I always think
that I should invite them over on my
channel
that would be interesting but yeah it's
something that I'd like to cover as well
the role of Venus in that in those
cultures especially the Mayan cultures
like astrology and astronomy and their
religious Cycles like you really it's
really impressive to go down to uh oh
yeah
and like see the first observatories
built in the new world for like tracking
the path of
Venus and just like they had a whole
calendar just around Venus Transit
Association really really amazing stuff
it's really they had a develop like
agnostic student had to developed deep
like Theology and philosophy there's a
great book out about the Aztec
philosophy
um actually written by a scholarship of
Spinoza who started sort of studying a
really like
reframes Aztec theories of time and
space and motion and it really puts them
in like Western philosophical categories
in a way that's it was really nice
because it allowed
Western philosophers access to
um so really important indigenous
indigenous listening it's a great book I
look forward to more research being done
on on that topic because I think there's
a lot to
explore not to explore that it's really
important that we do that because
otherwise what gets left what gets the
default image of the Aztecs
especially Aztecs is a conquistador
image of just like you know bloody
sacrifices yeah we like we it's funny
that often us Western People European
people will think of them as like oh the
aspects they're just like sacrificing
people every day and we're like
literally don't see Cortez murdering the
entire population
like you know we were walking around the
churches right uh in Amsterdam like one
of the one of the things that like blood
like boils my blood is like really
listening to uh Europeans just like oh
Muslims they just tear things down and
they can't stand they break all these
shrines and things like this and I
walked past a church just destroyed by
Protestants in the 17th century and like
iconic classic yeah you guys have done
your share of economy I want to hear
anybody uh you guys got to point fingers
it's going to get real uncomfortable
really fast yeah
it's like uh throwing stones in
a glass stained glass houses
it's literally that
uh we have a a super chat from zikdomov
who says thank you this panel has not
much of a question but a gratitude thank
you this panel has absolutely changed
how I see the world oh wow thank you
that's lovely I hope that's good
I mean yeah yeah if you're gonna spend
the next days crying in the shower I
don't know who I am anymore
thank you you always video destroy my
faith in God oh crap sorry
I hope not yeah considering that he's
super shocked that I guess that's
a good thing you have a question here
from alrum
thoughts on as eschatology itself and
its effects on religious societies do
you think they might be true predictions
or do they represent different ideas
question yeah I don't know if I can
answer that
well we can answer the first the
sociological uh do do eschatologies
affect religious societies here yeah and
maybe how soon
I think one of the things I guess I can
speak to about Judaism and be here
interesting one dear what you think Levy
too it's like one of the things I love
about Judaism is it's relative lack of
eschatology
like there's a great line like it's
better to not speculate those people
expect what I love at the end of the
world it's better they not come into the
world there's something about like don't
wrap into the world it's going to sort
itself out like the world's gonna be
fine let me sort your life out and I
think as we know we talk about sort of
apocalyptic religions and here are being
apocalyptic in in the sense of focusing
on eschatology not apocalyptically
strict sense
but those that religious belief is among
the more worrying beliefs to be
especially the idea that the world's
about to imminently end because it
allows people to basically abdicate any
responsibility for this world I think
there was a
there was an EPA guide here in the Nixon
the Reagan Administration who was asked
Point Blank like what are we going to do
about the ozone layer or whatever and he
was like well
do this that and the other but the truth
of the matter is that Jesus is coming
back soon we have to worry about it and
I'm like I don't want Jesus take the
will to be my my political strategy
um so I I worry about especially like
and also people the kind of moral things
they'll do to like immunotize the
eschaton right like we can force the
hand of God to come back by
it's not a powerful effect in human
history I think often for the negative
let me just say that the same phenomenon
can have the opposite effect too that if
the end is coming and you believe in
anesthetology where you will be judged
for reactions isn't that
might that make people even more keen to
like now I have to really really good
yeah as long as long as they
yeah I think it allows them to it
certainly makes it's a compulsion to be
pure and to purify with that Purity and
purifying often comes at the price of
things like the bonfire the band either
Savannah Rola or like
it rarely works out until I Live and Let
Live right attitude very rarely
um
in paganism you don't have much is
pathology either it's also very based on
the present
Ragnarok for the North
yeah yeah you have that in heavenly
interesting interesting the question how
that influences religious as a religious
Society
trying to think like the difference
between a religion or legislation like
paganism versus like Christianity or
Islam which would be like the Polar
Opposites in this case very much
concerned with eschatology and
not so much
to me that's true I see very much
Crowley's upbringing from his like
hardcore Protestant days this idea of
like this he's like he's a combo
apocalyptic prophet and there's like a
new way on and it's not it's not as good
I'm sure that I see that as
well I see it more as I mean even though
in the uh movement has something like
that you know which is the New Age of
Aquarius so I see it more as
a way of
um sort of brushing apart uh the the
past and sort of starting a new rather
than apocalypseism well I think that
even in Christian apocalypticism
like the world there's like a thousand
it began like this it doesn't really end
that's about the funny thing about the
end of the world is it's not really the
end it's just the beginning of the end
it's sort of like uh the world gets
purified and perfected and it's like on
the other side of things there's either
heaven or the new Earth or whatever is
it often the end of the world is not the
end of the world it's just the
transformation of the world in some
great new sense right and that's true
so I think eschatology broadly can like
in things like broadly speaking the end
of this world is what it's talking about
right as we know it right and that's
certainly true we can Judaism yeah if it
is true about also the end of a cycle
without
um you know that sense of Doom impact do
then I think that
yeah although you have also the Kali
hookah for instance so yeah maybe yeah
there is cathology and religions that's
true Ragnarok too because that's like
the end of the world but it's also a
rebirth right Boulder Boulder's son or
whatever survives but he's the only one
right
the young person
he's not mentioned by name but right but
someone someone's gonna count right that
might there'll be a later uh Agatha
Christian some Christians sticking that
in there yeah but but there seems to be
the idea that after Ragnarok there's a
rebirth rapid thing sort of
a beautiful world comes back but it's a
new world
yeah I think I think we might we just
speak up a little for the audience I
think there is a there is this
this tension in Judaism for showing
Jewish mysticism between the desire to
imminent the escaton to sort of make the
end of days now to like to end that uh
and like what someone like Gresham calls
the Jewish Messianic Mystics and others
is living life and defendant as if like
this this current moment is not good
enough in history and only when the new
thing starts the things get good and I
think it's what you were saying Philip
it very much depends on what the image
of that eschatology is like if it's one
in which all heathens burn and we roll
over our enemies then trying to
imminentize that Vision might not be the
best thing for a society or what we'd
like to see but
um but if the escheological vision is
one where the lamb shall lay with the
with the lion or you know a peaceful
version essentially then I think that
the attempt to imminentize that might be
a helpful one
um and there may be some sort of Despair
that if if this reality if this cycle or
this reality is is as it is nothing can
change nothing will ever change and
we're stuck under the powers that be
then why try and do anything I think
that the that imputes us to to bring the
end when that ends the positive one
ghosts
can be helpful
so the the curtain closes on its own
apparently yes we're trying to close the
curtain on this stage of History yeah so
the next one yeah and they're going to
to shut us down I don't know we're
locking it's over
kind of we kind of escaped here
privately and
then to hundreds of people also don't
upon me right right
it's an appropriate country to be in
baragnarok yeah
this is like the most like oops I was
the most holy place for the Norse right
it was like the the biggest holy shrine
it was a big one but I don't know if
we're considered the biggest one
I don't think the cult was that
centralized right now much more
spread out
and localized
but for sure it's an important it's one
of the important places Christian I mean
I guess I'm also reading that from
Christians who who yeah they really
argued that
because they really worked hard to like
depay and apply it
like took some effort
yeah was that one of the last places too
I think it was the last to hold out yeah
I think Griffin's really had a fight on
their hands because like the the last of
the Norse priests were also pretty
willing to right I mean they're going to
Valhalla you go in the boho defending
that place you're gonna really fight
hard to think of Christians had a really
difficult time
a decision upon and they really made a
big deal and they did a big nice church
that's yeah and then upside became like
the center for Christianity yeah yeah oh
yeah it was like Barry I think that that
was a I think the part of that was
really rude
really about
yeah yeah unfortunately
everyone's had their trouble with the
Christians yes
including other Christians
uh serious question here
soon you believe that God's made heavy
metal
yes
only the dogs
not God just the gods right
in the devil
right
he had a hand in there
good stuff
do any of you know your zodiac
not really my Zodiac oh my son yeah oh
yeah yeah sure I'm uh
Capricorn
I think I'm the same as you yeah we are
both of parents you can tell that
Pisces Pisces oh sweet
that means
it's a little funny because I I only
know like really technical Hellenistic
astrology I know absolutely nothing
about modern Sunshine astrology so it's
I I know next to nothing about
what any of That's supposed to be
question for Dr puka
um what's going on current trends in
European paganism
characters
what's up it sounds like a journal
Insurance in European paganism yeah
um
that's a good question so current trends
who are
a trend towards
the eclecticism and now pagans are
moving more towards traditionalism or
multi-traditionalism
and what other Trends I can see the
people are not
meeting in in groups as much especially
younger Generations I actually gave an
interview recently about that
and one of the reasons might be that uh
younger Generations are more used to
interacting and finding their
communities online
but it seemed like in the past there was
more even though they were probably
fewer pagans and my main frame of
references is Italy here because that's
where I do my field work even though
I've researched European veganism as
well but I think that
yeah there's also a trend towards
practicing more by yourself or having
your community online because that way
you can find exactly the people that
align with your word view and that have
maybe work with the same panty owner
with the same deities whereas when you
go to bigger groups on pig or pigment
modes Pagan modes are usually the once a
month meeting that pagans have
um you will find that the other peoples
well pigeons are not that many so in in
a play in a city you will find that
there might be I don't know 10 people 20
people and they all have a slightly
different take on paganism and different
practices so it's a bit difficult to
have
a practice together that's why for
instance in Italy one thing that
happened was to the the Pagan groups in
Italy attended and probably still tend
to have a more eclectic weekend-based
approach because there seems to be more
inclusive so that you have sort of the
the main things that you find in
tokenism uh in a week and way because I
think the wika did a very good job but
syncretizing many things and putting
them together like well like you did
with the wheel of the year for instance
and creating things in a new way that at
the same time
gives you a blueprint of paganism that
you can shape however you like so
there's a there was a trend about
having The Eclectic type of paganism so
that it's a bit more inclusive than
welcoming and then everybody will
obviously have their own specific
tradition but I think people pagans are
now moving more towards more away from a
wild eclecticism and either try to be
eclectic eclectic in a more systematic
way or being traditionally sort of moved
to traditionalist which means that you
can work with different deities from
different pantheons or different
Traditions but uh you see those two
things are separate you don't mix
together Hecate and carnos for instance
but you may work with Hecate in a uh
sort of reconstructed Hellenic way and
work with cornunos and and a weekend way
for instance and that would be
multi-traditionalism whereas an Eclectic
approach would be to work with both of
them at the same time which is also
something that you find I'm not saying
that eclectic pagans don't exist anymore
they very much exist but I think that
there is a trend towards more
traditional approach
how many pagans are there in Europe it's
impossible to say that's one of the
things that we had a lectured University
I think a couple of years ago and we had
a discussion
my PhD supervisor and I about how
impossible it is to determine how many
pagans are there because
pagans elude statistics because some
figures would identify as pagans they
would identify as
Druids or as heathens or as something
else so they would identify with the
with one of the things that Scholars
would still consider to be part of the
paganism umbrella and there are also
pagans that would say oh I I practice as
a pagan but I don't want to use the
label so I think the paganism as a
religious movement and the pagans tend
to elude a little bit that kind of
big margin of error
like ten thousand two thousand plus or
minus five thousand even with a big
margin of earlier
I will have to
know latest research because certainly
UK they do they do pretty good polling R
and that stuff I think right religious
polling yes but there was the
conversation that I was having was about
religious okay but I can't remember the
numbers now off top of my head and I
would have to check the latest research
but it is a growing religion I think
that I saw recently an article in the UK
saying that paganism is the fastest
growing religion
so uh it is it is a growing religion and
I think we will see more opinions not
for me I don't see it ever becoming like
the
um as big as I don't know Christianity
but it's definitely a fast growing
religion
so it's another time our next event is
downstairs 6 30. is that the welcoming
thing yeah okay
so we should probably wrapping up pretty
soon yeah
I'm also hungry yeah
dude I forgot about food this is the
thing with these cerebral people we sit
around all they're talking about the
ontology of things and forget that we
need calories to live I don't forget it
I could get it it's just an interesting
question and we can you guys just tell
me when you want me to stop pulling out
questions and we can wrap it up yeah
um again from smashing paper tagus is
the growing tendency towards religion
being individually tailored and eclectic
as we're discussing here the unique
product of Irish talk a moment but were
there similar Tendencies earlier in
history
certificates I think it has everything
to do with liberalism I think it has to
do with the access the wide access to
information because in ancient times uh
you didn't have access to as much
information about different traditions
and cultures as you have now you would
probably you know a very limited amount
you would have access to limited amount
of information about religion so you
would others start with what you have
been exposed to or you generally had
much less exposure to information
whereas now since we have the internet
and YouTube channels and and all of that
and and talking about religion
I think that that's that's a massive
Parts because you I can see even in my
research
with certain folks tradition
eradicated Italian culture they are
starting to become more eclectic because
of the internet uh for instance I did a
part of my PhD research was on
vermacular healers in Italy and they
tend to be more in rural places in
places that are not as as much in
communication with the big cities and
they tend to be quite local and they
would transmit they were passed down
from generation to generation without
that much variation but in recent years
thanks to internet and that is
admittedly on the part of these
practitioners thanks to the wide access
to information if you have been exposed
to a certain tradition and then you read
online about I don't know
um the Goddess Diana and you feel a
sense that you are
um you feel drawn towards that goddess
you will say oh you know what maybe I
can try and incorporate this practice
that my grandma did with the moon and I
can syncretize and I can also work with
Diana at the same time so I think that
the wire access to information is
definitely one of the major reasons why
we have a more individual interior
approaches there are individual examples
in history I'm thinking of people like
khabib in India or maybe Guru nanak the
founder of Sikhism and it's interesting
because they those were people who lived
in an environment where they had access
to all these different Traditions like
Hinduism a particular the Hinduism and
Islam in this case
um whereas in maybe other regions of the
world it would much it is relatively
more closed off in terms of information
regarding other registration
and that would really only speak for
your point here is that today that we
live now in an environment where most
people have that access to all kinds of
information to some degree so I
definitely agree with you I think it's
also a function of how we conceive of
ourselves since the 17th century as
individuals uh many Asian people also
thought of themselves as part of a
community and the
it wasn't the unit of religious election
wasn't the individual it was the
community so I think of places like
Alexandria where at least in magical
practice we see we see some syncretism
but in the actual religious communities
there's not much blending
yeah you don't like the the Egyptian the
indigenous Egyptian religion the
Christians that you saw themselves very
differently and you see very little
cultural crossing over there even though
they had access to the information
but the idea was no I don't pick my
religion like I don't that's not to me
it's a it's a really community-based
religion it doesn't just survives in
some traditional communities where the
idea is like it's not about what I
believe it's about how my beliefs fit
into a larger network of community and
what's normative is actually what's
about the community and not what I
believe
I'm trying to like that I prefer that I
think it's also a matter of cultural
identity I think that in the past there
was more of a political and social need
for having a strict
social identity like for instance as I
don't know Italian or whatever it was so
there was a sense that you had to build
that that sense of identity via the
tradition
and now with the globalization I think
that there this needs is less felt so
you can see that not just with religion
but even with other things like
um the the cuisine you know now you see
that you can eat the types of food from
different regions and different
countries which in the past was not
exactly something that you would find as
easily so you can eat sushi and then go
to Mexican and then to the Italian
restaurant so you have also the
integration of different cultures and
it's not seen as a threat to your
cultural identity whereas in the past I
don't think that you would have seen
that much mixing in this way obviously
synchroducers have always happened but
it's not quite the same as the
globalization yes it'd be funny to meet
a person who's like a food a culinary
fundamentalist Italian yeah
says that outside of Italy is fake food
you have to come back and eat real food
because what you have over there is
faithful
maybe maybe we're doing one more
question then yeah the Super Chat here
from before question is from Seth fee
Phillip please cover every page of
shamsamar
I'm on it
I'm gonna take like two decades or
something but
how much of the how much of the in the
recent English translation which is
covered in the text
first I think eight chapters
which would be like
maybe ten percent it's really a
substantial well maybe a bit more but
yeah it's just
relatively tiny portion yeah
yeah it's a pretty Monumental work yeah
which is also just Grist in the middle
of how much we've talked about this at
the round table just especially in the
Islamic kids near East context
it's a really huge gap in our
understanding of like for those of us
who include the near the the Middle East
and what it's called the West it's just
a
you know of what we don't know and not
don't have translations for
it's amazing how again it's like how
islamophobia and this like and uh
has just destroyed our like the
narrative we all are carrying around
with us is going to be so fundamentally
revised that
most of the work that we're doing now in
like in the next 200 years is going to
be really silly it's going to look
really primitive actually
that's why the scholarship of people
like Liana seif who is here today
actually is very very important I have
the Arabic version of the Champions at
home it's like it's like this
basically it's a big
Big Tiny type too
here is a final question
which is uh there's been a few questions
around around this I thought we can pull
them together question is from Zev how
would you advise me to build a group of
people to help build a new religion
laughs
do you want to be like the leader of
this religion like a cult
let's say let's go with that
a beard
is a good start yeah they tend to have
the
um no seriously I don't know that's a
difficult question I mean I think it's
why would you do that why would you want
to do that I mean I think we know pretty
well how so-called Cults operate right
separate people from their families
don't allow people to access to contact
like love bombing
um
and then like
you know there's a these psychological
techniques are pretty well understood at
this point the the real sad thing is
that there are probably out there
actively using them to right
um also I tell people to
these techniques like I'm mentioning
love bombing uh other kind of things
like that these techniques are really
well attested and if you find yourself
in a religious setting or a a business
settings also use these techniques to
like build business solidarity like
literally business like corporate
businesses have gone and looked at cult
studies I mean like what do they do
they're like let's do that to our you
know like it's really Sinister right so
I would really encourage people to look
at these like Signs and if you ever find
yourself in any group whatsoever whether
it's a political group or a religious
group or a corporate group and you can
see them doing this stuff to you
run get out of there and also in
relationships like
like the same kinds of psychological
techniques like really harshly judging
someone and then like showering them
with love afterwards it's a really well
understood technique that like people do
to like
to manipulate people's emotions it's
really frightening yeah I I kind of like
the Aesthetics not know what they do
often but the Aesthetics of Cults and I
was joking with a friend that we started
called with the acronym compassion
understanding and love and tolerance
kind of use the group psychology to try
and make this problem
I think also another thing I wouldn't
trust any cult leader they didn't have
some badass clothes like I want like I
want them to have some like really cool
like that was the first thing when I
looked at David koresh I was like I
don't trust that dude he's not dressed
cool enough like yeah you need to have
like like uh you need to dress like
somewhere on the Star Wars Spectrum
right so who do you think of the four of
us uh would be would be a better cult
leader let us know in the comments I
vote Phillip Phillip is like the he's
like it's like the The Still Waters Run
Deep yeah
I bet you could pull a great you grow
your hair out but you get some great
like uh great uh what's his name the
Russian guy
yeah yeah
you don't see this over the counter but
I feel like that's very pissing eyes and
fast in there right they'll put people
under spell
ing so be careful so I don't if I shower
you with too much love yeah
technique yeah yeah I get it bill I see
what you're doing
I was happy to see my initiates
television homeism it does sound like a
religion
go we have to get going to drop yes yep
yeah we're gonna in fact begin the first
sectarian fight right the Philippian
Council
nice thank you yeah we should get some
food yeah I think it's time to wrap up
um some wine going just want to express
again like like we said in the last live
stream it's such a amazing honor and and
just a lovely thing to be able to have
this community with you guys in person
and also with with the audience of
course it really means so much to us I
think I can speak for all of us yeah
um that we have this this platform to
speak about things we are passionate
about
um and and have have you in the audience
be along for that Journey we were in
Amsterdam last week at least the three
of us we got to meet some of some of you
like in person and that also was an
incredibly special experience
so thank you all so much for for being
there for watching and for engaging with
with all of our channels
um if you guys aren't subscribed to to
these guys you should definitely go do
that and right away do you want to like
pitch your channels Seekers of unity
history and philosophy of mysticism with
a extra focus on Jewish mysticism
perennialism and um trying to look about
how it might be helpful to us in a
contemporary Global moment uh
existentially in other ways
my channel is Angela Symposium and I
cover academic research and academic
scholarship on Magic esotericism
Shamanism paganism and a whole topics
I'm esoterica and my channel focuses on
the academic study of Western as a
terrorism so Kabbalah Alchemy Magic
other stuff yeah any so the esoterica
grab bag great
go subscribe thank you all so much for
coming and being part of this live
stream we're gonna go get some food
they call it live through now
thank you so much we're gonna get going
maybe you want to try out bye bye
there it is and
they're not